We want you to understand that you may
have to outsource your development
to a developer.
As part of that,
you should have a solid understanding
of what it takes to build an app.
Having a good foundation will
allow you to make sound business
decisions over time.
You may also have big ideas for
what you want your app to accomplish, so
we want you to understand what
comes standard in a platform
versus what would need
to be custom built.
The latter will take a lot
more work to implement.
We should probably go
over some vocabulary.
Our next two text nodes will
cover some basic vocabulary
you should be familiar with
before you talk with an engineer.